Thank you all for coming.
Tonight we're going to talk about a very serious
subject.
Um, the situation that we face with antibiotic
resistant bacteria.
Antibiotics were once the silver bullet that
seemed to be able to cure just about everything.
Now we look at 23,000 antibiotic resistant
bacterial infections every year.
So let me introduce you to our panelists.
Our first participant is the Director of the
Wisconsin Institute for Discovery at the University
of Wisconsin-Madison.
She was a science advisor to President Barack
Obama.
Please welcome Jo Handelsman.
Our next participant is a professor at Rockefeller
University where he is head of the Laboratory
of Bacterial Pathogenesis and Immunology.
Please welcome Vincent Fischetti.
Our next participant is an associate professor
of Immunobiology and Microbial Pathogenesis
at The Salk Institute.
Please welcome Janelle Ayres.
Our next participant is the Evnin Associate
Professor at Rockefeller University.
Please welcome Sean Brady.
and finally the Singer Professor of Medicine
in Microbiology, and the Director of the Human
Microbiome Program at NYU School of Medicine.
Please welcome Martin Blaser.
Uh so, I thought that maybe a way to start
would be to show a video.
This was an experiment that was done at Harvard
where basically scientists created at sort
of gigantic petri dish, sort of kind of the
size of an air hockey table basically, and
they seeded it with bacteria on either side
and then basically laced it with antibiotics.
Starting at the edge with pretty mild levels
and then as you go further in, it gets more
and more deadly until the central band has
a thousand times the lethal dose for Ecoli.
It's really kind of mind blowing.
We're going to see the bacteria, so just sort
of hanging out there and now they're multiplying.
This is sort of time lapse, so when they hit
that point, what they're encountering that
as antibiotics and then how are they getting
past it?
I mean you can see them.
It takes a little bit of time and what they're
waiting for is growth of one or a very small
number of cells in the population that are
already resistant.
And so although there were many, many billions
of cells crossing the plate, probably one
in a million would have resistance to the
antibiotic, so once those started dividing
and-
So they're dividing and one in a million just
happens to gain this power to get past it?
Well, they always had the power.
It was preexisting in the population, but
then when the whole population is, the rest
of the population is stopped by the antibiotic
because they're inhibited by it.
Then those few that are resistant start proliferating
and then they take over and that's exactly
what it looks like in similar terms when it's
in the body, you know, you take an antibiotic
and most of the bacteria will die, but there
will be preexisting mutants in the population
that are resistant.
That's great.
Well not great, but it's amazing.
It is definitely not great.
Yeah, no it didn't.
I know, I know.
Don't get me wrong.
We think of antibiotics as, as the sort of
heroic triumph of science.
I mean, how did, how did we get to enjoy the
benefits of antibiotics?
I mean, how did that begin?
Well, it started with a chance discovery from
a by Sir Alexander Fleming.
In the UK, who found a fungus on his plate
that was clearly inhibiting growth of staphylococcus
on, on the Petri dish, and he recognized what
it was that this was a compound that was diffusing
into the Auger and determined that it was
what we now know of as penicillin, but it
was many years before it can be used in any
kind of broad scale way because he discovered
that in 1929 and by the start of World War
II, we still, we're not using antibiotics
and they weren't in general use.
Why not?
I mean you, you discover a drug, you know,
put it into practice.
I mean, what was the holdup?
They couldn't make enough of it.
That fungus produced some but not enough to
go into large scale production.
And so during the war a scientist named Ken
Raper was worked for the USDA in Peoria and
he decided as a war effort to put out the
call for penicillin producing strains of penicillium
mold.
So he told everybody in Peoria to collect
as many fruits and vegetables with that green
blue fuzzy thing that you see on your bread
and fruit to bring those to his lab.
And people did and he had this large collection
and it turned out it was his own technician
who has gone down in history, as Moldy Mary
now.
Her name was actually Mary Hunt and she brought
in the winning cantaloupe and it had a strain
of penicillium mold that produces more penicillin
than any other natural strain to this day.
And so they started, they moved it right into
commercial production and started pumping
out large amounts of penicillin and they have
enough to be able to ship it the penicillin
to the troops in Europe.
And so World War Two was the first war in
which more people died directly of bullets
and bombs than the infections that accompanied
them.
Wow.
So, and then once, once the war is over, then
antibiotic start to become more of just a
general medicine for the public in general,
right?
Yeah.
And at the same time there was interest in
soil bacteria that produced antibiotics.
And, and then after the war there was just
this explosion of knowledge of people, culturing
organisms from the soil, screening them for
antibiotics and then moving into production.
And so we had dozens of antibiotics coming
onto the market in the next decades.
Sean, I mean, how would you sort of describe
like the sort of, the overall benefit of these
discoveries of penicillin and some of these
other early antibiotics?
I mean, what I mean overall, like in terms
of lives saved or someone, what are we looking
at in terms of the scale of this?
I think one of the figures that penicillin
alone has saved 100 million lives.
And that's penicillin alone.
Yeah.
So if you think about that single picture
that Joe talked to you, you see it in almost
any microbiology textbook.
That image has probably saved more lives than
anything in the history of science.
So you want one kind of thing in your office,
you should hang that picture as a scientist
because it's made a larger impact on human
health than anything but, but that, that whole
discovery, even today we're still using those
antibiotics.
So.
So that's the initial discovery, then you
think about almost everything that came out
of what we call the golden age of antibiotics,
the forties, fifties, and sixties.
So people were finding things not just on
cantaloupe but in other-
They are culturing soil bacteria largely and
finding antibiotics.
Almost every class of antibiotics that we
use today was discovered in that that time
period.
We have relied on antibiotic defense really
of those molecules and continually using versions
of those molecules up until today.
And that's why we're in the position we are
today.
We, we've largely ceased discovering antibiotics
after the golden age, the late sixties, early
seventies.
Because we thought we were done.
We thought we had solutions to these problems.
That's how good those initial discoveries
were.
How, how much of an impact they made on human
health.
What's your sense of like when it started
to become clear that things weren't going
so well?
Like when?
When do you think that the sort of scientific
medical community said, I think we have a
problem?
Well that happened pretty quickly.
I mean we were seeing resistant organisms
to penicillin early on.
It was, it started
Like a matter of a few years after?
Probably a year or two
After the introduction of penicillin.
Exactly we already started to see early stages
of resistance, but you know, was it an organism
here, an organism there, but, but it was occurring
at that time and it's been occurring at an
accelerated rate since then.
Right.
So Marty, what do you think is, what would
you say would be like one of the main factors
that explain sort of how we got to this point
in terms of resistance?
Like what are we doing that is causing all
of these bacteria now to be just so dangerous?
So, uh, the short answer is that Darwin was
right and that is that there is survival of
the fittest.
It's selection.
We are using antibiotics in such magnitude
because of the miraculous nature of antibiotics,
both the public and the profession says, well,
why don't we just treat this person with antibiotics
even if their symptoms are minimal.
So there's enormous pressure, selective pressure
of antibiotic use and it's just, it's just
a mathematical certainty that there'll be
resistance, but it's not linear.
It's, it's geometric because of the properties
of bacteria growing.
Yes, but you have to remember that bacteria
come, most of them come from the soil and
antibiotics are in the soil, so they've learned
for millions of years how to deal with antibiotics.
So the systems are there for as long as you.
If you expose them to antibiotics, those systems
become heightened, then become resistant.
So they, they've seen these drugs or similar
drugs or antibiotics type molecules for hundreds
and hundreds of thousands, millions of years.
Marty, you, you've also been talking a lot
and writing a lot about the fact that our
antibiotics are not precision weapons that
you know, you use them against Ecoli, MRSA,
and so on, but that's not the only thing that's
going to affect.
Yeah, so so antibiotics came of age when we
were, when we were really trying to eliminate
these bad pathogens, but no one really considered
what was the effect of the antibiotics or
the normal bacteria living in the body, the
normal bacteria that we call the microbiome,
but now it's clear that that when you take
an antibiotic for a skin infection or lung
or urinary tract infection, that antibiotic
is getting everywhere in the body and it is
selecting for resistant organisms in that
body.
That's suppressing some organisms and other
organisms are coming up and maybe some organisms
are becoming extinct as well.
So these are organisms that we might actually
depend on.
It might be actually beneficial for us.
And so in fact we know that one of the main
defenses against infection are our residual.
Our normal organisms there, there, there,
the coast guard, they are protecting against
invaders.
They don't want to share their turf and 50
years ago it was shown that if you pretreat
mice or other laboratory animals with antibiotics
and then give them a pathogen like Salmonella,
the, the level of Salmonella that it takes
to kill the mouse goes down by four logs,
you know, by 10,000 falls.
So Sean, I mean someone might say like, well
we have all these gigantic pharmaceutical
companies.
There's lots of money that they can throw
at the problem.
You know, there was penicillin and then there
were other things I can think of mycin and
you know, you know, science marches on.
So we've got like more in the pipeline, right?
That's the unfortunate thing.
We have almost nothing in the pipeline.
Almost nothing.
You can, you can ascribe that to a number
of different reasons.
We don't get in a crisis because of one thing,
but we get in it because many things came
together that we probably didn't foresee.
One of them being that our first round of
antibiotics worked so well right?
That golden age of antibiotics when we were
describing them, people thought we were done
and so so over the next ensuing 30 years antibody
discovery programs, both in academic and industrial
settings largely shut down and so there are
almost no pharmaceutical industries that are
putting at least the effort they used to put
in to finding antibiotics.
The second thing is then if we'd been using
antibiotics, the same ones for 30 years, that
means they don't cost us anything anymore.
They're all generics.
You can get an antibiotic for somewhere between
free and twenty cents a day in many parts
of the world, so now you have an infrastructure
that doesn't exist and you have a financial
structure that doesn't support the development
of antibiotics.
So we are at a certain point trying to figure
out how to restart that pharmaceutical industry
and how to make it worthwhile to restart it.
Have to be some major things changed.
It's in direct competition with chronic disease
which is much more lucrative for the companies
because it drug you take for the rest of your
life is obviously going to make them more
money than a drug you take for five days and
then stop, and so even even now with the crisis
that we all know we're in, very few companies
want to move back into that area.
And what they're doing is taking a drug that
worked, became, an organism, becomes resistant,
and they just make a modification on that
drug.
It's cheaper for them to do that than to start
from the beginning and now the virus can become
resistant much more rapidly.
So they work for maybe a year or two and then
they can't use them anymore.
Marty.
And then there's yet another problem and that
is that bacteria don't respect borders and
so what that means is that if, if a resistant
organism arises in another country like India
or China, it doesn't take too long for it
to come over here and because antibiotics
are so inexpensive and because people think
that they're so miraculous.
In many of these countries, people are able
to get antibiotics over the counter, no prescription
necessary.
Parents are giving their kids 10 courses of
antibiotics a year in, in some recent studies
funded by the Gates Foundation, tremendous
antibiotic pressure, very low cost, but somebody's
making money on those antibiotics.
Resistant organisms are arising and then there
are the crossing all over the world,
So this, so this sort of cheap marketplace
of antibiotics over the counter and so on
is even helping to drive on-
The whole antibiotic market is broken.
Antibiotics are in one sense too cheap and
and, and are therefore overused and abused.
And on the other hand there's no incentive
to create new antibiotics that we want to
keep and put in reserve for important infections,
which won't affect tens of millions of people
so that there isn't that market.
So the market, the economic model for antibiotics
is just broken.
Just, just to put a number on that, right?
Yeah.
So the most recent, they're going to differ
a little bit, but let's say the six months,
recent antibiotics that came to market made
about $10,000,000 each last year.
10, 10 million each.
Right?
Okay, that seems like a lot of money, but
just let's say you've done all the clinical
trials you need and now you need to synthesize
a production scale an antibiotic.
It's $150,000,000 investment, right?
And the reason these things make a little
money is, is you don't want to use them.
You don't want to use in this frontline defense,
right?
You want to put them in reserve until you
absolutely need them.
And so where's the incentive?
If, if forget the hundreds of millions you
put into development, just to make the thing
costs you 10 times which you can sell it for,
sell it for a year.
We really have to rethink how we, how we market
these things, how we as a community decide
we're going to put antibiotics in reserve
and put an upfront and of realization that
these things are there.
We need to pay for them as a community because
we're going to need them some day.
Alright, so let's, let's brighten things up
a bit by like actually, you know, you folks
are actually working on things.
So maybe we'll start.
We'll start with antibiotics themselves, with
new antibiotics.
So with Jo and Sean's work.
So, so, so you've been going back to the soil,
the soil that brought us all these original
drugs.
You think you think there are more there for
us to find?
I do.
I'm so, for a long time I went to other methods
for antibiotic discovery and you'll hear about
some of those that Sean's developed soon,
but the reason I did that was that there were
some references from the nineties that said
that the soil was mined.
It was fully tapped and I've gone back to
the data and I can't find the data and so
now I question whether that's really true
because in the ensuing decades my lab just
spontaneously discovered antibiotics, novel
antibiotics from soil that hadn't been discovered
and we weren't even looking in some cases.
And so I.
It just occurred to me one day, wait a minute,
it's not mined if we're finding them and so
that's the approach we're taking is going
back and asking what is the frequency of new
compounds?
There was one paper that said the rediscovery
rate would be 99 percent, so if you found
100 compounds, 99 of them would be already
known.
Well that's actually not so bad if it's true
because we can look at a lot more than 100
compounds with today's methods, but.
But I'm not even sure that that's true because
it wasn't really based on at least published
data.
Maybe somebody in a pharmaceutical company
has the data, but we haven't seen it.
So are there particular places that you like
to go look for new antibiotics?
In a particular soil that is you like or is
it just in your backyard?
Well, we're looking at across the world, so
we have a worldwide network of undergraduate
students.
Undergraduates who are a fantastic and very
creative workforce.
So we developed a course that is known as
the Small World Initiative and it's taught
in 15 countries and all over the United States
and about 10,000 students a year take the
course and they dig up soil from whatever
environment is interesting to them and they
come up with more interesting reasons than
I ever would for why an environment is interesting.
And and so they have this great variety of
soils.
They're isolating very interesting antibiotic
producing organisms and now we have to go
into the next stage which is figuring out
what antibiotics are produced.
So we think that if we have 10,000 students,
each one gets at least 10 antibiotic producing
organisms per year.
That's a lot of candidates.
And so if we can crank through enough of them,
even if that one percent rediscovery or 99
percent rediscovery rate is correct, we still
have a lot of new compounds to look at.
So Sean, what kind of approach are you taking
to searching for these, these new antibiotics?
So about 20 years ago now, I guess, Jo and
a few other people were thinking along these
ideas, thinking about is there a reservoir
in soil still of, of natural products and,
and the thing that that percolated to the
top of the thinking of these people was that
there's data from even longer ago, maybe 120
years ago that it appears we don't culture
most of the bacteria out of the environment,
that actually the bugs we've been playing
with represent a small fraction of the bacteria
in the environment.
So let me ask you, so if you like take a sample
of a little sample of soil, first of all,
like how many microbes are in there and how
much DNA are you talking about that you're
looking at from all of them?
So it depends on whose numbers, let's say
is there's thousands, maybe 10,000 different
microbes of which we culture about one percent.
Just one percent,.
Just one percent.
And again, people have done better nowadays,
but they don't solve the other problem, which
is even if we can culture bacteria, we don't
turn on their genes.
Right?
So even if you can bring bacteria in the lab,
they don't know how to turn on the genes,
they're gonna make antibiotics for us.
And so, so what we want to do is just look
at their DNA and you can get huge amounts
of DNA at least in the context of molecular
biology out of a single gram of soil.
And so it's the coming together of this idea
that we can culture bacteria.
We can sequence their genomes and we can.
We can mess with genes, right genes in ways
that we can turn them on that really allows
you to untapped this reservoir that's been
tapped or untapped.
So.
So Vincent, I wanted to, to kind of shift
gears here and look at a way of dealing with
bacteria that's totally doesn't involve antibiotics
at all.
Um, there's, and this is, this is kind of
a long running idea of basically sending the
enemies of bacteria against them.
I mean, can you explain the idea of this kind
of approach?
What was sometimes called Phage therapy?
Well phage therapy actually started before
antibiotic therapy.
So, um, it was discovered by D'Herelle about
100 years ago.
He discovered a, he had a vessel in the, it
was cloudy with bacteria and suddenly it disappeared,
just disappeared in his eyes.
And he said some things in there that killed
the bacteria, figured out that it was, it
was a virus, a virus that only infected bacteria,
bacteria phage, it's called.
And that started a revolution at the time
to use phage to control infection.
It was well before antibiotics.
So these, so these viruses, they're back,
they're known as bacteria phage.
So what are we looking at?
So the blue thing is bacteria.
The blue thing is the bacteria and the ring
around that is the cell wall of bacteria.
When it attaches, it injects its DNA into
the cell and once that DNA gets into the cell,
it takes over the self for the production,
a new virus particles and once those virus
particles are produced, the phage have a problem.
They have to get out of that organism and
they solve the problem by producing an enzyme
called the lysine that drills a hole in the
cell wall.
And since the pressure inside the bacteria
is greater than the external environment,
the organism explodes and releases the bacteria
phage that had been produced in the environment.
And that's phage therapy using those phage
to kill the organism directly.
What we've done is now taking that enzyme,
the specific enzyme that drills a hole in
the cell wall, we can produce it recombinantly,
and when you add that enzyme externally, it
does precisely what it did from the inside,
drills a hole in the wall membrane externalizes
and kills the organism, so we've developed
the enzyme that the phage now uses to release
its progeny phage.
You could use phage themselves and that's
called phage therapy as a means to control
bacteria, but you can use the enzyme to to
accomplish the same thing.
And there are particular species of phages
that can go after particular species of bacteria?
The very specific, that's the problem with
phage therapy is that they're highly specific
for the organism that you're going after.
So in order to kill, for instance of Staph
Aureus, you'll need to produce a cocktail
of maybe five or six or 10 or 15 phage to
get around the chance of organisms becoming
resistant because the bacteria become resistant
very rapidly to phage.
So they getting resistant to the phages as
well.
Antibiotics, they're just evolving,
But that's.
That's the normal system.
The phage are trying to get into the organism,
the bacteria trying to keep them out.
So that balance has been going on for a billion
years.
Nobody wants to win that war, phage that want
to win because if they win, all is gone.
If the bacteria when.
Well they can't get enough DNA into them to
to, to, to modulate their, their, their DNA
themselves.
Right.
Because bacteria are taking in.
They are taking in DNA and so they need that.
That acquisition of phage DNA that doesn't
kill them, that allows them to pick up genes
if they, allows them to survive much more
rapidly.
So then there's this molecule that phage make,
this enzyme called lysine, and so you want
to just try just using lysine rather than
the whole virus.
We've been using lysine for almost 20 years
now.
We have lysine and the beauty of lysine is
that they are very specific for the organism.
We don't see resistance, we'd never seen resistance.
We've been doing this for 20 years that they
cannot become resistant to lysines because
they'd have to remodel their cell walls, so
it would take them a very long time to become
resistance.
Probably hundreds of years before they become
resistant to actual lysines.
So those are anthrax organisms and we've added
lysine to them and you could see what happens
to them.
This is real time.
They just explode and disappear.
So you can take 10 billion organisms in a
test tube and add up five few micrograms of
lysine, within a couple of minutes, they're
gone, so it works quite well.
We have enzymes and they're quite specific,
so you don't run into the problem, the antibiotic
problem where you kill everything.
Your normal floor and the and the organism
you're trying to kill that.
Quite the, the, the, the staff enzyme will
kill staff.
Anthrax enzyme kills anthrax.
So you, you're, you're targeted killing.
You're not affecting your normal flora.
So why isn't everybody using lysine?
I mean, what's the, what are the challenges
that you still face?
Well, we're in clinical trials right now phase
two.
Phase one showed that it was quite safe.
We're in phase two in the hospital.
So about 117 patients which would sure be
done by the end of this year, treating MRSA
infections, endocarditis, MRSA, septicemia
and Endocarditis.
Heart infections?
Heart valve infections and septicemia, bacteremia
and we'll know by the end of the year.
So Janelle, I mean you had touched on this
earlier about, you know, maybe paying more
attention to our own sort of host health in
terms of dealing with these infections and
you know, you're, you've been doing a lot
of research into, into tolerance.
Maybe you could sort of describe sort of the
overall idea that you're pursuing and then
how do you know how that might translate into
an actual treatment for a patient?
Yeah.
So I think that the, uh, what is evident to
me with our perspective, uh, in developing
antibiotics and antibiotic history and the
approaches that have been described by my
fellow panelists is that they're all based
on the question of how do we kill microbes
and developing ways to kill microbes.
And we are approaching this from a different
perspective.
We actually want to understand what it takes
to enable a patient to return back to a healthy
state and to survive infectious diseases.
And um, there's, we, I talked about sepsis
and how in sepsis and this is the case with
other infectious diseases as well, there're
significant physiological damage that occurs
and that leads to physiological dysfunction.
And in order for a patient to return to a
healthy state and to survive an infection,
they have to be able to.
You have to be able to alleviate that damage
that's occurred, um, and, and restore the
patient back to normal physiological function.
And our assumption is that if we just kill
the pathogen, we should be able to do that,
but that's not necessarily the case.
You can have patients where antibiotics are
effective in them, but the physiological damage
that they've endured kills the patient anyways.
And so there's, we are taking a variety of
approaches to understand, um, if our body
encodes ways to protect us from infectious
diseases by promoting health and alleviating
physiological damage.
And about 10 years ago now, we discovered
that in addition to our immune system, which
protects us from infections by killing pathogens,
we've discovered that we encode a distinct
defense strategy that we call the cooperative
defense system.
And this is a defense system that, um, is
essential for us to survive infections.
And it protects us by executing what we call
tolerance mechanisms or disease tolerance
mechanisms.
And these are mechanisms that our bodies encode
that alleviate physiological damage during
microbial interactions.
And so these are mechanisms that promote our
health without killing the pathogen, so you
can induce these, um, tolerance responses
in, um, a host and they will be perfectly
healthy and survive the infection despite
having the pathogen present in their body.
Um, and we like this approach because this
provides a new avenue for treating infectious
diseases that will enable us to promote survival
of the patient, but they also, um, in theory
should be what we call anti-evolution proof,
meaning that pathogens should not evolve resistance
to such strategies because we're targeting
the, the patient and the physiology that's
affected by the, um, the infectious disease
without having a negative impact on microbial
fitness.
It almost sounds like the microbiome is so,
so complex with hundreds or thousands of species
that, how would you ever disentangle it well
enough to be able to make it into medicine?
You have to have a hypothesis.
You have to conduct clinical trials.
Clinical trials have advanced cancer therapy.
They've converted HIV infection from a lethal
disease to a completely treatable disease
with longterm step-by-step clinical trials.
That that's what the field needs.
Of course, that's what we need in to to restore,
to have working antibiotics, to develop new
antibiotics as well.
Yep.
Sean.
We do similar things with the human microbiome
to do the soil because we look at the molecules
that these bugs make and we've in fact found
antibiotics that are effective against MRSA.
So these are.
These are antibiotics made in our bacteria
living inside of us.
Coded by the bacteria living inside of us.
And we're sort of antibiotics factories.
Yeah, we, yeah.
We may not need to undergraduates anymore.
We may just have to mine our own microbiome.
Or the undergraduates'.
To add to the complexity, we also have bacterial
phage in our gut and they are modulating.
So we have phages that are attacking our bacteria
inside of us all the time.
We eat, drink phage all the time.
Ten trillion phage pass through our gut into
our tissues everyday, everyday.
So they're everywhere.
There's 10th of the 31 phage on earth, so
they're everywhere.
We eat, drink phage all the time, so they're
in our gut, they're modulating the organism
up and down, so you have a bloom of phage
and they are killing these particular organism.
You have a reduction in up in that organism.
We don't know what physiological effects it
has on our bodies, but it has to have an effect
and, and understanding the modulation of phage
and our gut flora is a, is another area that
people are starting to look at.
And then Janelle, like your own body is then
responding to all these different things going
on inside of you.
I mean.
Absolutely, it's a bi-directional relationship.
So, um, we're, we're recognizing the microorganisms
that are in our intestine, but also some microbes
induce host responses or immune responses
to that are not effective against themselves,
but will be effective against other microbes
within the community.
So, um, through this, bi-directional communication,
it goes back to ecology 101.
They're, they're using the host to also shape
that ecosystem.
So I'm gonna open it up to questions in a
little bit.
But before I do that, I just wanted to get
a sense from all of you about sort of the
human side of all of this.
I mean, we, we talked about how the industry
incentives are all quite perverse and you
know, it takes time and effort to find these
antibiotics or to develop these other alternatives.
So are there, do you see changes in a good
direction in terms of, of, you know, creating
a sort of these scientific or social customs
or, or, or procedures to help get us towards
this better situation where you might use
the, these things?
Or are we just going to, you know, like not
be able to define these replacements because
there isn't enough support for it.
And Marty, what do you think?
The bottom line is that we need to be better
stewards of antibiotics.
We could create 10 new antibiotics or 10 new
lysines, but unless we use them better, uh,
the, uh, the resistance will get to us.
The bacteria are, are selected for resistance.
So we're, we have to reduce the variation
in antibiotic use.
They're using antibiotics a lot less in Sweden
than they are here.
People are just as healthy as we are here.
There's a lot of regional variation in antibiotic
use.
There's variation from doctor to doctor, the
the practice, the public have to be better
stewards.
Understand that antibiotic use has cost.
We're using it as if it had no cost.
So you think that we could even now, I mean
not even talking about these amazing possibilities
that we've just discussed, you think that
we could reduce the amount of antibiotics
that patients are taking and still be protecting.
That will help us decrease the pressure.
You know, one of the questions is why did
C diff move out of the hospital into the community?
Why did MRSA move from the hospital into the
general community?
But we might be able to get it back in.
Right.
So Janelle you were just nodding before.
I mean, do you think.
I think there's some great data from antibiotic
clinical trials from 1920s and 1930s where
with certain trials, the, the group that received
the placebo, 80 percent of them did just fine.
We can clear infections on our own.
We can survive infections on our own, um,
and I think a lot of times by the time a patient
shows up to the clinic to get the antibiotics,
they, there are studies to suggest that they've
already cleared the infection and now they're
just getting antibiotics because they have
some residual symptoms from the infection.
So I completely agree with Marty that if we
can just temper our use of current, um, antibiotics
that will help significantly.
And what about you Sean?
You were just talking about like, um, how
much money an antibiotic might make and how
much money is required to do it.
So like how do you, how do you even, how do
you get those thing numbers to balance out?
I think the good thing is we've seen this
tremendous effort in the past decade to try
and solve the discovery problem.
We still need more money there, but we clearly
see there's global impetus to say we need
more antibiotics.
Maybe there're, I think there're 50 recognized
major efforts in the past decade to, to support
antibiotic discovery internationally.
So I see that going in the right direction.
I really do.
I don't know that it's going to happen fast
enough, we'll ever get enough money, but that's
in the right direction, but it's the post
antibiotic issue.
Not only our use, but how do we market it?
How do we, how do we let those things survive?
I still think we have a lot of hard thinking
to think about how we're, how we're going
to do that and I don't think we have, we have
a solution.
We have great examples we can go to.
There are lots of things that countries do
to put things in reserve.
You can say our army is in reserve until we
need it.
Right?
We pay a lot of money for that.
Why not think of same models for antibiotics
that we have them developed.
They're in reserve.
We pay for them prior to their use, but before
we need them.
I mean there's a lot of thought that has to
go into that, but to me that's where the gap
is at the moment, but we need more money for,
for, for development of antibiotics.
We see money flooding in.
We still need more, but there's really still
this question of how do we use them afterwards
and how do we finance that worries me.
What might help is the fact that we've been
using for years and decades or a broad spectrum
antibiotics and they're killing everything
and the reasons for that is when you're sick,
you go to the hospital and the clinician needs
to know what he's going to treat you with.
If he doesn't know the bug that's causing
the infection he has to give you something
that's broad spectrum.
If we had diagnostics at the bedside, so if
someone comes into the hospital and we know
exactly what organism's causing the infection
you can treat with an antibiotic that is specific
for that organism.
Would have very little effect on your normal
flora, but we're not at that point.
We're close.
Our hospitals now can identify the organism
fairly quickly.
Fairly quickly meaning what kind of time scale?
Hours, so we're at hours from days to hours.
And if that.
If you can do that, then you have antibiotics
that are more channeled to the organism that
you're killing, which would cause less side
effects.
And I think that that might be a way to survive
this type of issue that we're having right
now.
And then what about sort of uh, these, um,
less, we'll call them less conventional things
like phage therapy or using lysines or so.
And do you like in terms of getting a regulatory
approval for these things, do you do, do you
think that that is able to move forward quickly
enough or.
Or are we, do we need a better way to sort
of like take in new ideas and try to get them
approved to be used?
Well, the lysine therapy has been quite successful
in moving through the system.
Phage therapy has an issue, because phage
therapy is, is a concoction of many phage
to control a particular infection.
And since you could make a cocktail, I can
make a different cocktail that causes the
same infection.
There is no IP so there's no incentive.
The develop phage therapy if it does work
to some degree, but there's no incentive there.
But if you have a defined molecule then that,
I think that the pathway to get it out out
the door is quite good.
Alright.
So Jo, I'm just curious, are you, when you
look ahead 50 years, do you see the sort of
the dark picture they recast earlier or do
you, are you optimistic?
I mean what's.
I'm always the optimist, but I also have to
be tempered by the fact that we developed
a plan for antibiotic development and stewardship
when I was in the White House and there were
some really simple things in there that could
have been done like stewardship of antibiotics
in hospitals.
So CDC has an eight point plan of what hospitals
are supposed to do.
We found that only 50 percent of hospitals
in the United States followed that very, very
simple plan, like having a strategy for an
antibiotic use in the hospital, training personnel
in antibiotics.
It.
It was really kind of depressing and appalling
and we identified all the things mentioned
here and then many others that we need to
steward the antibiotics, use them less, have
better diagnostics so that we know when to
use them and we don't even use the tools today
that we have like diagnostics.
I've, I've done this survey completely unscientific.
I shouldn't even talk about it, but it's my
little way of keeping tabs on the docks.
I asked in my lab, when people go for a sore
throat, go to the doctor, what do they do?
And 10 years ago there was never a test.
They just gave them the antibiotics in every
case.
And then slowly we started seeing the strep
test, strep throat test being used.
But even today, fewer than half are getting
a test before they get antibiotics.
That just seems irresponsible to me.
Any guesses why?
I mean Marty, what do you?
I mean you're the doctor?
I mean why, what?
I mean what, it doesn't make sense.
It's the problem of transparency, the medical
profession and the public overestimate the
benefit of antibiotic and they underestimate
the cost, the effects of antibiotics.
And so, uh, we, we have, we have to fix that
and I, I really agree about narrow spectrum
antibiotics, you know, and, and as I said,
antibiotics are falsely inexpensive, why,
why give someone a $500 or $5,000 antibiotic
when you can treat them with a $5 antibiotic.
So the market's broken, but we need to use
tax money just like we need to use tax money
to buy interstate highways, uh, that, that's
a public.
Antibiotics are public good.
We have to invest in, in, in antibiotics that
will protect our future, uh, as, as a public
good.
Okay, um, we have microphones.
A question right in the back there.
Thank you first off for the presentation,
that was really useful.
Um, I just have two quick questions.
So first I'm being.
So how advanced and what are the, what is
the percentage accuracy on these diagnostic
tools?
Can they either be improved or is it just
because these current antibiotics are cheaper,
they're just not getting that much visibility.
And my second question is, are there currently
government programs that are in place or in
the pipeline?
And the reason I ask this is because there're
orphan diseases out there that don't have
a large market either, but yet there are a
lot of government programs that incentivize
the innovations for this space.
So I'm wondering if that's something that's
happening in the pipeline right now that will
encourage innovation in the space.
Great.
So let's, uh, let's, uh, let's take these
one at a time.
So Vince maybe you could start us off in terms
of the diagnostics.
Is it just a case that we already have really
good diagnosis but then they're just not being
used enough?
Or are there a possibility to develop new
kinds of technology to really get these things
identified fast?
Well, right now they're doing it by DNA analysis.
So how does that work?
You just get a number of organisms, a few
organisms from swab and they can take it and
put it, extract the DNA, put it through a
machine and identify certain genes certain
pathogens have.
And they can do that within hours.
Sometimes they'd have to grow the organism
very for only a few generations to get more
organisms so they can extract more DNA.
But it's quite quite accurate.
It just takes a little more time.
It's not at the bedside.
It's a few hours, but it's better than what
we used to have which was overnight.
We'd have to culture it, let the grow, organisms
grow overnight and then even another test
usually two days before you get the identification.
When you say at the bedside, are you saying,
I mean like a doctor comes, a nurse comes
and takes your temperature at the bedside,
takes your blood pressure at the bedside or
you're saying-
Well like a rapid strep test is in a sense
at the bedside.
You can swab the throat and put it into a
solution that digests the organism and they
have an antibody that identifies a molecule
on that organism.
You can do that within 20 minutes.
You get the results of that experiment.
That's at the bedside.
We're not there yet, but we're close.
And are hospitals like.
It sounds from your, from your survey, I would
guess that maybe hospitals are a little slow
to really snap up the best of these diagnostics.
They are used.
Some are and some aren't.
Just like the simple practices to reduce antibiotic
resistance, which don't cost any money and
in most cases some adopt them and some don't.
And Marty,
I mean most antibiotics used in the United
States and most countries are used in outpatients.
They're not used, so the focus, 90 percent
of the antibiotics are used in outpatient,
and most of the antibiotics are used for upper
respiratory infections, which we know that
a big fraction are viral and are not bacterial
at all, so viral infections don't respond
to antibiotics.
So we need a rapid diagnostic that will tell
whether that outpatient walking in has a viral
infection or bacterial infection.
In the doctor's office as well.
If we had that tool, we could eliminate a
lot of unnecessary antibiotic testing.
One of the problems is that the antibiotic
costs $5.
The test might cost $500.
So our health system isn't, It's not working.
Okay.
So after we get fix antibiotic problem, we'll
fix the healthcare system, right?
Or first, what if, at the same time.
Anyway, the second question was about what?
What are, what are there?
Are there any special government programs
that are actually like trying to, to push
research about resistance forward with what's
happening?
So as, as you mentioned, I'm on this commission
that Jo was involved in setting up called
PACCARB, which is President Obama set it up
by executive order and, and our mandate is
to combat antibiotic resistant bacteria and
we have five different areas, surveillance,
stewardship, new diagnostics, therapeutics
and international efforts working with other
countries.
So as, as part of these and, and the executive
order, uh, money's have gone into something
called BARDA, which is to develop new antibiotics,
to put money in, to make it more economically
viable, to develop antibodies, to look at
antibiotics like orphan diseases as well.
They're, they're special stipulations that
make it more attractive for companies to make
products for orphan diseases.
Great.
Any more questions?
Is prevention still a big thing in terms of
the washing of the hands thing, is that still
the best thing we can do?
I have one little version of that.
I try not to touch anything when I go to the
men's room.
Does that work?
So soap and water works.
There's no question, but on the other hand,
there are all these antibacterial products,
uh, that are killing the good bacteria.
Good bacteria help protect us against the
bad bacteria against the invader.
So are they doing more good or good?
Doing more harm.
And I don't know either.
These things have hardly been tested and the
people who make them aren't particularly interested
in testing.
So we should, we should just talk a little
bit about.
I mean, we've lot, I've been talking a lot
about the gut, but the skin is covered in
bacteria, right?
And it's a completely different flora than
we have in our gut or our mouth or our ears.
In fact, the two hands differ a left and right.
So.
And are they, are they, are they doing, are
they doing good things for me right now?
Yeah.
They're protecting your skin just like they
protect any surface they're on, they're good
guys.
You have to get used to this respect for the
microbes thing.
Okay, okay, now I can handle this.
And so, so if you use these sort of hand sanitizers
with the antibacterials-
There are times to use them in the hospital,
it's very important to use them because you
have a lot of bad bacteria transmitting in
hospitals.
So washing the hands and a variety of different
ways is important.
And during flu season it's very important
because flu is transferred by people's hands.
But if you take all of that collectively,
maybe that's three percent of the time.
The other 97 percent of the time, the benefit
is just leaving our microbes alone.
I think the biggest thing any of us can do
is treat our flu symptoms very respectfully.
Stay home, not, so you don't transmit it,
wash your hands with soap.
Purell won't help with flu, but uh, that much
but certain, oh, well yeah, get get you saying
get the shot.
Get a vaccine.
That's right, and because I think more antibiotics
are given for flu like symptoms that turn
out to be viral, but we don't have the test
to prove that than probably any other disease,
so I think if we kept the flu under control
and that can be controlled just by behaviors
and washing hands and breathing in people's
faces.
When?
Usually November or December till our early
March events.
Vince?
You have to realize that 90 percent of infections
come in through the mucous membranes.
They're not coming in on your hands.
They are coming in through mucus membranes.
Your eyes, your your genital track.
So when you touch something that's contaminated,
you're not getting infected through your skin.
It's when you touch your nose, or you touch
your mouth that the organism then gets it.
That's how it gets in.
You have to have a wound.
Your skin is a barrier.
The only other way is a wound.
You're bringing the organism from where the
other, whatever you picked up and you touch
your nose and how many times you touch your
nose and your mouth.
About 12 times an hour for the average person.
Wow.
In the back there.
I think multiple of you stadia, but you were
basically because you were using bacteria.
No, because you were developing and what do
you got?
Penicillin and all which came from soil bacteria
and therefore the soil bacteria had natural
built in resistance to the compound you were
using.
A question, is it possible to synthetically
generate proteins or protein analogs which
would bind to sites or would interfere in
other ways with mechanisms for which things
have not developed resistance to because they
weren't.
They aren't actually naturally occurring equivalent
to penicillin.
Yeah.
That's actually an interesting point is that
I think they've done studies right where like
they would look at old soil and actually actually
find that there were some resistance, resistant
microbes like before the invention of antibiotics.
That's right.
They're all over it.
My, my group has studied a site in Alaska
that's essentially as pristine as you can
find a site on earth and it has very little
exposure to antibiotics and we find a large
array of antibiotic resistance genes.
We also have found that when, purely synthetic
antibiotics had been introduced on the market,
resistance has even faster in some cases than
to the naturally occurring ones.
Penicillin's been on the market for what,
60 or more 70 years and it's still useful.
Some of the this synthetic antibiotics can't
even be used anymore because there's so much
resistance, so we're dealing with evolution.
I think that's the answer to the question
of why there's no universal cure or prevention
because we're dealing with evolving organisms.
So I guess the lesson is that bacteria are
pretty awesome.
They really are.
All right.
Well let's give a hand for our panelists.
Thank you for coming.